and Russia has launched A Fresh Round of
Drone strikes on Ukraine After promising
retaliation for saturday's Attack on
Belgrad the Ukrainian Air Force Says it
Shot Down 21 of 49 drones launched by
Russia But at least 28 People were
injured in the Attack of the City of
hark  Russian officials say The New Round
of strikes Hit residential buildings
Medical facilities and a Hotel housing
Military commanders and Foreign
Mercenaries both sides have increased
Gothel Kharkov Palace and also Budinok according to
Vuli Girshmana bulo was completely destroyed by
hitting with
Iskander missiles close 1 year
nights in povitrya over Kharkov came  group of
Shai Yak at least cha first she yake in me behind my
back there is a living Budinok in the very center of the
city fortunately leaving the data about suffered
them with us there
is no such thing as we have New
Year the gift they gave us for the New
Year black souls are just black
souls after all in the elderly quarter
here  same
people, how is this
possible? The Armed Forces of Ukraine launched a
strike using multiple
launch rocket systems on the city of Belgorod,
which resulted in the death of
civilians, including children.  The
Kiev regime, with a high-precision
missile strike on the former hotel
complex in Kharkov Palace, killed
representatives of the Main
Intelligence Directorate and the Armed Forces of Ukraine who
were directly involved in the
planning and execution of the terrorist attack in
Belgorod.
budinki that apartments poshkodzhennya
terrorist tse respectfully to the right both on the
private and on the mistsevoy
RV operation 17 people suffered from the VD
chergovy strike and for such a blow in the
Kharkiv region in our Kherson region in a hundred
villages of Donetsk region binge region for the Armed Forces strike
in Odessa Sumy region in all our other hundred
regions  for kozhen shakhet for kozhnu ross
rocket will be fair into the distance of the
terrorist powers and red-handed and even more
practical